we go to the u.s supreme court where joe
biden today reaffirmed his commitment to
using race and gender as the basis for
deciding who to nominate to fill justice
breyer's soon-to-be vacant seat here's
joey earlier today
a person i will nominate will be someone
with extraordinary qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
i'll meet with the potential nominees
and it's my intention my intention to
announce my decision before the end of
february i have made no choice at this
point
thank you all so very very much for
being here and i'm not gonna take any
questions because i think it's
inappropriate to uh take questions uh
with the justice here he's still sitting
on the bench
i'm not allowed i can't do it i'll get
they're gonna yell at me and everything
and i won't get my ice cream cone anyway
so right off the bat biden is excluding
all potential candidates who are not
african-american women but ask yourself
isn't this agenda in and of itself
discriminatory imagine that we put out a
poll he said okay next time i'm on
vacation you get to pick um the fill in
for this show and they have what two
categories only can you choose from you
decide uh would that be fair anyway
picking candidates based on race and
gender it's not only extremely divisive
but likely unconstitutional the supreme
court in its own jurisprudence has ruled
that classifications based on race are
subject to the strictness of scrutiny
and has found that discrimination based
on race unconstitutional and as law
professor jonathan turley has pointed
out the president will only consider a
black woman woman for the next
nomination a threshold gender and race
condition that the court itself has
found unconstitutional for schools and
unlawful for private businesses so the
question is is it okay for joe to do it
and why is he doing it is it you know
it's not because he's deeply concerned
about racial justice
we know that's a lie because remember he
did work with robert the former klansmen
byrd he wanted to stop the integration
of schools because he was worried about
schools becoming in his words racial
jungles
no joe biden is being bullied into the
decision by the new extreme left they're
using the supreme court pick as another
way to flex their power show their
strength its identity politics on
steroids in short biden was forced to
make this decision for example far left
new york congressman
jamal bowman tweeting out mr president
you promised us a black woman on the
supreme court let's see it happen
congresswoman presley added quote it is
time for a black woman on the supreme
court now this all raises the question
how much was breyer forced out is he
retiring on his own terms on his own
timeline apparently not we're also
learning tonight that south carolina
congressman jim kleinberg clyburn jim
clyburn single-handedly helped save joe
biden's candidacy after poor showing in
poor showings in iowa new hampshire
sounds like jim clyburn is admitting
that he had a quid and a pro and a quo
with old joe in terms of okay clyburn
would save joe's faltering campaign and
use south carolina and his popularity
which is huge in south carolina and
exchu in exchange extract a promise from
joe only to put an african-american
female on the supreme court is that the
only deal they made is there more to
that deal what other deals might be out
there and furthermore ask yourself if
far-left democrats and the mob and the
media are so concerned about racial
diversity on the court and so concerned
with racial and gender justice why are
they so hell-bent on smearing clarence
thomas every chance they get you know
remember over at msdnc he was just
recently referred to as uncle clarence
listen to the ladies on the hard-hitting
news show on abc the view actually
suggesting that justices thomas and amy
coney barrett are traitors to their race
and their gender for not being far-left
activist judges that they want take a
look
you pointed out first black woman
there's only been two black men in it
that those numbers are a little shocking
and one doesn't really represent the
black community
the supreme court is like this
dictatorial branch of the government
these are people who are appointed by
their own people
they do not answer to the country amy
coney barrett uh was put in there
because she's a white woman yeah who
they say well she'll go against abortion
rights and she's a woman oh so that was
deliberate i think clarence thomas a a
black guy a black man a justice okay
i'll give it to him he's a smart guy but
he is to the right of attila the han
this guy and they put him in there
thinking oh a black man will go against
voting rights which is what he does
identity politics flat out racism and
bigotry but to the mob the media there's
only one standard for democrats and then
another standard for far left judges and
then one standard for the rest of us
when it comes to selecting judges
respecting the rule of law judicial
philosophy the commitment to upholding
the constitution should be the main
factors determining who you're going to
pick now these important decisions
should not be made solely based on race
or based on gender in fact it's
disrespectful to the nominee to do so
but because biden's presidency is
frankly imploding even democrats in the
media mob are now admitting it he's now
desperate to try and placate his
democratic base that he's losing in
droves as new numbers now show him at
absolutely low dismal 34 approval rating
in the key state of georgia look at this
poll from the atlanta journal
constitution by the way they didn't like
me they actually said in their year-end
edition about me in 1996 it was a great
year for atlanta the olympics came and
sean hannity left i left to come to fox
news anyway it's no secret why stacey
abrams wanted to be nowhere near biden
when he was in atlanta earlier this
month joe biden is failing on policy
failing on messaging failing everywhere
in between as gallup finds biden
crashing when it comes to key character
traits like leadership government
management and good judgment during
times of crisis i'd also add cognitively
as well empty rhetoric empty promises
empty shells and empty suit that's
pretty much sums up the joe biden
presidency and now he's so desperate for
a political win he's willing to go all
out and try and appease the radical
extreme left who are now pulling the
strings and have been pulling the
strings of this failed presidency for
democrats joe biden it's politics first
it's you the american people we're dead
last hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else